der vesuv ist einer der gefährlichsten
vulkane weltweit doch an ihn grenzt ein
noch exklusiveres gebiet die pflege
eschenfelder ein supervulkan ein
britisches forschungsteam hat jetzt
herausgefunden dass dieser supervulkan
deutlich häufiger ausbricht als waren
bislang angenommen hatte steht hier
womöglich einen ausspruch kurz bevor
klicks um science-fiction jetzt täglich
fasziniert es seins videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen am vesuv rom ortes
in direkter nachbarschaft liegen die
flex eschenfelder ein gebiet in der nähe
von neapel das von eruption herden
durchzogen ist und somit geprägt ist
durch seine starke vulkanische aktivität
eine katastrophe denn die region dort
ist wirklich dicht bevölkert die
menschen dort sitzen also auf einem
pulverfass und genau deswegen haben
forschungsteams weltweit die entwicklung
dort ganz genau im blick so auch
fachleute von der university of oxford
die jetzt herausgefunden haben dass der
vulkan namens campi flexray wohl
häufiger in die luft fliegt als man
bislang angenommen hat und das bedeutet
auch dass die intervalle in denen der
supervulkan aktiv wird deutlich verkürzt
sind zu dieser erkenntnis kamen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weil sie bei bohrungen in neapel und
nordöstlich der caldera
entsprechende ablagerungen gefunden
hatten vulkanische gase nämlich ein
material das in der fachsprache auch als
material del monte tief bezeichnet wird
bei der analyse stellte sich heraus dass
dieses material aufgrund seiner
chemischen zusammensetzung zu einer
reaktion vor 29.000 jahren passt dieses
puzzle teile hat den bislang in dem
großen rätsel um europa supervulkan
gefehlt denn entsprechende ablagerungen
waren zwar schon in der vergangenheit in
see und meeressedimenten im
mittelmeerraum aufgespürt worden dazu
heißt es in der studie
diese vulkanische asche schicht y 3 t
frage genannt bedeckte mehr als 150
tausend quadratkilometer des
mittelmeerraums doch bislang war nicht
klar welche vulkanen sie zugeordnet
werden musste obwohl die analyse dieser
raschen und tush sich zeigte dass es
gewisse ähnlichkeiten mit dem auswurf
der flex eschenfelder gibt doch
direkten umfeld des vulkans konnten
trotz intensiver suche bislang keine
hinweise auf eine eruption zu diesem
zeitpunkt gefunden werden und so gingen
experten und expertinnen bis jetzt davon
aus dass es in dem hochrisiko gebiet der
fleck reschen felder vor 40 und vor
15.000 jahren zu eruptionen kam bei der
ersten handelt es sich wohl um einen
extrem gewaltigen ausbruch der ganz
europa mit asche bedeckte die asche
wurde sogar bis nach russland
geschleudert die super eruption von
15.000 jahren war im vergleich dazu wohl
schwächer hatte es dennoch in sicht doch
die aktuelle studie zeigt jetzt
eindeutig dass auch dazwischen wohl
keine ruhe herrschte sondern es auch
zwischen diesen beiden ausbrüchen heftig
gekracht hatte dazu der beteiligte
forscher paul albert die verteilung und
das volumen der ablagerungen sprechen
dafür dass der materie del monte foods
aus einem ausbruch der stärke 6,6 stammt
vergleichbar also mit der eruption der
flex eschenfelder vor rund 15.000 jahren
und auch hier hat der supervulkan wohl
dafür gesorgt dass es über dem gesamten
mittelmeerraum zu einem ascheregen kam
diese stärke ist zudem auch vergleichbar
mit der des ausbruchs des indonesischen
vulkans tambora im jahr 1815
dadurch starben nicht nur mehrere
zehntausend menschen sondern es gab auch
folgen für das klima nicht umsonst wird
das jahr 1816 als das jahr ohne sommer
bezeichnet diese neuen erkenntnisse aus
oxford sind von großer bedeutung denn
jetzt steht fest dass der kapitän in den
vergangenen 40 tausend jahren eben nicht
nur zweimal sondern dreimal explodiert
ist wie gesagt befindet sich dieser
feuerwerk in der nähe einer der dicht
besiedelten regionen europas und so
wären millionen menschen in gefahr
zudem häufen sich in der jüngeren
vergangenheit die hinweise dass der
vulkan aktiv ist und sich regt
untersuchung hatten unter anderem
festgestellt dass in der letzten zeit
vermehrt gasaustritt und sich wohl auch
vermehrt mack maine untergrund ansammelt
so hatte beispielsweise ein
forschungsteam aus der schweiz 2018
festgehalten dass der nächste große
ausbruch wohl schon bald bevorstehen
könnte darauf kamen die fachleute weil
sie eine art langzeit mama modell
erstellt hatten dies deutet wohl an dass
sich die bedingungen im magma
system verändert haben müssen und sich
dort nun eine möglicherweise gigantische
menge an glühender flüssiger
gesteinsmassen angesammelt hat im jahr
2016 hatten fachleute aus london
muster von bodenhebungen in der nähe des
supercups hingewiesen die wohl dafür
sprechen dass man an einem kritischen
punkt sei welche folgen ein ausbruch für
die region und auch für ganz europa
haben könnte ist umstritten die region
würde höchstwahrscheinlich von einem
ascheregen begraben werden und der
himmel über italien würde sich
verdunkeln das gas partikel gemisch in
der luft würde zahlreiche todesopfer
fordern
ganze städte würden unbewohnbar und die
vulkanasche würde den flugverkehr
lahmlegen katastrophe durch supervulkan
hat die nasa die lösung würde ich mal
sagen also anklicken anschauen
abonnieren also hier draufklicken bis
dann